[Music]
hey
everybody yeah here we are once again
see who's here our last live stream
before the weekend
man goes in alex is in tammy's in i
can't believe you guys come by
every day to like watch us yapping yeah
that's so
that's sophie or i'm gonna call her
benji
then she's in
now i did see that mango says because
today we're talking about the
uh mike flanagan uh he didn't direct the
entire series but i'll get into that a
little bit but he's the showrunner on it
uh the follow-up to the much lauded
haunting of hill house this is the
haunting of bly manor
uh which just dropped on netflix and i
finally got to the end of it last night
i was like binging all the episodes
going i
watched that i want to like review this
tomorrow so it's like you know because a
bunch of people
ask me about it now i don't because i
know that mango just said that you
haven't watched it yet but you want to
watch it so it's like i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna spoil any of the big
reveals but
i mean i might say some [ __ ] that is not
necessary i don't know it's not
necessarily like meant to be spoilery
but i'm just saying that if you really
really want to watch this series without
really knowing anything about it
then maybe maybe maybe you might not
want to watch so just in case i
accidentally say something that like
ruined some [ __ ] for you i don't know
what that's gonna be
it's a nicely made series but i really
didn't give a [ __ ] about it
well you weren't even watching it and it
was one that like you really have to i
mean much like the haunting of hill
house it was one where you really had to
like pay attention to
background details and pay attention to
like conversations and stuff like that
because everything like meant something
and like tied into something else
um so i will say that um haunting of
hill house which i've watched through
two times um was
i think i liked that a little bit better
but
maybe only just because haunting of hill
house was like scarier than this one
like this one is still like has some
creepy [ __ ] in it it has like some
creepy imagery
but this one is more like a gothic
romance than um a straight-up ghost
story but it has like horror elements in
it
so kind of know that going in also
even though it is uh ostensibly based on
the turn of the screw
and um the first couple of episodes are
very much like an adaptation
not even so much an adaptation of the
turn of the screw is i think it's more
the
adaptation of the innocence uh you know
which was also an adaptation of turn of
the screw but there's some stuff in here
that's more an homage to the innocence
than to the original story like the
statue garden and
stuff like that and the song that flora
sings like that was from the movie and
not from the original story
but i will say too that this
and even at the beginning like in the
opening credits it even says
it doesn't say based on term to screw it
says based on the works of henry james
so there is a whole bunch of henry james
stories
in here that are referenced and straight
up adapted
and that are kind of like um tied into
the ongoing narrative which is largely
based on
uh turn of the screw so you got like one
episode that is basically straight up
based on
uh the jolly corner which is another um
story that he wrote
you have one that's sort of um
that is almost a straight-up remake of a
story that he wrote called the roman
uh a romance of certain old clothes or
something like that
that's like a kind of a flashback sort
of episode
um so that's like a straight straight-up
adaptation of that story
there's also um references to
one of his novellas which is called the
beast in the jungle
um there's not like an adaptation of
that per se but there
the theme of that is like a recurring
theme of the show
you know what i mean so there's like a
ton of like other
references to henry james work in this
so it's not just a turn of the screw
adaptation
it also it's kind of like ties into a
bunch of his uh you know different
stories as well
i will say too that this the part of it
that is based on
turn of the screw is a much closer
adaptation to turn to the screw than
haunting of hill house was to the
shirley jackson novel
because i mean that one as much as i you
know i really liked the haunting of hill
house you know the show
but um it wasn't really a straight
adaptation of the shirley jackson novel
by any stretch of the imagination it
just kind of like
took a couple of things from it and then
like kind of expand it out into its own
story which was cool you know i liked
that
so the one thing about this that's kind
of different than
the first season because like i said
this isn't this is kind of like american
horror story
uh if you don't know in the sense that
each season is going to be like its own
standalone story but it's going to have
like a lot of recurring actors
um and maybe some recurring like
thematic elements
so one thing like a bunch of there's a
bunch of the same actors in this that
were in haunting of wheelhouse they're
just playing completely different roles
also i noticed the score was the same
which i thought was very interesting i
thought that was like an interesting
uh thing that they did and some of the
thematic stuff is the same
although i feel like this one is kind of
more concerned like i feel like the
first one
was more worried about the fa like the
crane family like all the siblings
and how like growing up in hill house
had like screwed up their lives like in
various ways
and how um and and how that kind of
impacted their life later on
whereas i feel like this one is kind of
has a little bit of the same themes but
it also kind of had a thing where
this one was much more like a love story
and one that was
not and not just between two particular
characters but
between several characters and also
something about
memory and um living your life
not worrying about like when you're
gonna die or being afraid to love
someone because you're afraid you're
gonna lose them
um things like that so there's a lot of
that kind of stuff in there too and that
like several of the stories kind of tie
back to that central
theme about memory and about like people
forgetting about you
and about things like that so which was
kind of referenced a little bit in hill
house like with
uh i think like nell's speech about like
memories being like confetti and stuff
like that so there's a little bit of
that going on in this too but
it's kind of a different focus so
it was it's nine episodes and basically
the story
is that i mean it's been modernized it's
set in
well the main part of the narrative is
set in 1987. um
you have a uh a nanny or she's a
schoolteacher
named danny danielle um whose last name
is actually clayton
which is a reference to jack clayton the
guy who directed the innocence
so like i said there's a whole bunch of
little easter eggs in here like that
and she goes to england
to escape some at first she don't know
like some kind of trauma that she's
happened in her past because she's like
running away
so she goes to england and takes a job
as a nanny for these two
creepy kids uh flora and miles they're
not like they're not overtly creepy but
i think that's like
one of the best things about the show is
that they the kid actors in this
are great um the little girl that plays
flora
fun fact she's also the voice of peppa
pig which i didn't know until i looked
at that peppa pig
it's a it's a like a little animated
kids show okay that's like a little
british kid show
about about a little pig named peppa but
she's cute
she is cute cute as a button so like her
and
uh the kid that plays miles are really
really good in this um
because they have a lot of weird [ __ ]
they gotta do
so it's like i like that they're kind of
like
the way that they're creepy is not like
straight up
like oh no creepy kid but just some of
the [ __ ] they do
is just like really weird and like
behaviorally you're like what the [ __ ]
is going on with that
so it's like you know like i said not so
overtly creepy but you don't know what's
going on so it's like intriguing like
what is these
deal why are these kids acting like that
why are they saying that kind of [ __ ]
and this is another one too i think the
interesting thing about this
show is that like i said overall
i think i liked the haunting of hill
house a little bit better but maybe only
because it was like creepier or scarier
this one a little less scary but i
noticed that
when i finished this one and i haven't
watched it a second time yet which i'm
sure it will benefit from because
there's like a whole bunch of [ __ ] in
there that i missed evidently
um but after i finished this one i
felt a lot more compelled to like go and
read other people's like
summations of them and like theories and
things like that
which i didn't feel i had to do as much
you know what i mean with haunting of
hill house
i feel like this because it had so many
more
because it was just not concerned about
one family's story it was kind of like
all these different people but they all
had the same thematic [ __ ] going on but
it kind of all like had to do with this
house um so i think there was like a
bunch of [ __ ] in there that i missed now
if you don't know like because one of
the best things like a lot of people
liked about haunting of hill house was
all the ghosts in the background that
like they kind of didn't
you know it wasn't it wasn't a kind of
thing like boo ghost or anything like
that they always kind of put [ __ ] in the
background it was like really subtle
um they do this a lot in this one too
but
the cool thing about this one is that
all the ghosts in the background um
spoiler alert uh they do
actually like come into play in the
story later on are they it's explained
like who they are
or they're mentioned or something like
that so they're not just there like to
be creepy or anything
they actually do like have a little bit
of bearing in the story and i think
most of them's backstory is at least
referred to at some point so they're not
just there for atmosphere they do
actually have to
tie in with like the history of the
house and everything so like i said
there's
um you know there's just kind of like so
much going on in this
that really the first couple episodes
like i said are
kind of i don't want to say it's a
straight up adaptation of turn of the
screw because it's not
but that's kind of like where the bulk
of the story comes from but then after
that it starts going off in different
directions
i think probably probably my favorite
episode even though it took me the
longest to get into because i was like
what the [ __ ] was going on i think it
was the fifth one
it was the one where the housekeeper mrs
gross
who her and the guy that plays owen the
cook
they were like the best i loved those
two characters i think they were like
the best characters them and the kids
were like the best characters in the
whole
series um but the one where she was like
going through that weird like time loop
and they were like showing all this
stuff like
memories that she had and everything and
like i said i can't say too much about
it because that'll be a spoiler
but um but that episode i think was
really good and also i think the second
to last one
was probably my favorite one as well but
like i said this is one
just like a haunting of hill house you
really really really have to
watch this one twice because when i was
reading through a bunch of like i've
even missed like a lot of [ __ ] ghosts
man like some people even said like in
the first
uh the first episode they were like oh
yeah like there was this plague doctor
and he was like
in the background it was like dude i did
not even see that a single [ __ ] time
so i wasn't even paying attention
obviously
but um but that does come into play
later on
but everything in it ties back to
something else and it all gets resolved
now one thing i will say um some people
have been criticizing
uh carla um gagino
who is in this who's obviously liking a
lot of mike flanagan's other stuff
um she had to have like a
sort of a yorkshire accent in this and
it's not
entirely successful i mean it didn't
bother me that much
but i was just kind of like a little bit
of it was just kind of like
weird and then like i've seen some
people from the uk online being like oh
my god it was terrible
you know what i mean so it's like so i
so i don't know like british people
might watch it and they don't know
i knew that it wasn't i mean i know
she's americans and i know she doesn't
talk like that
but so i could tell that it was a little
bit it wasn't too bad
uh henry thomas who plays uh henry
wingrave
his accent was also a little hit or miss
um but not too distracting nothing like
that
so some people i'm just saying some
people have criticized that one thing
that i thought was very funny and this
is something that i never thought of
before
but i've seen some british people say
what is it
with americans making like you know
horror movies or ghost stories or i
think that are set in england
and it's like you go out at night and
there's like crickets they're like
we don't have that it's like it's not
they're like they're like
yeah but it's like it's not like they're
like it's not the everglades it's like
it doesn't sound like that outside so
they're like every time that happens
you're like oh an american must have
made this
because it's like you're like yeah like
you go outside at night in britain and
it's like you don't hear like
people like crickets all the time but
it's like [ __ ] i never even thought of
that
you never find american actors that can
do uh in british accents
for the most part uh i think it's
because you know
our actors get hired based on that
casting couch and
coke all right but that dude from
[ __ ] the walking dead
that dude sounded like a southern dude
andy lincoln yeah
yeah yeah everybody shocked my dad i
actually
didn't realize that he was british
because i know you know that god did you
know i know he was british
i know he was in love actually before
that but i hadn't seen that movie so
it's like
yeah i know my dad's [ __ ] a hardcore
southerner and
mississippi as [ __ ] and he thought that
was a real slightly because yeah that's
right we're being represented
as a british dude oh yeah god damn it
god damn
sounded just like a southerner laura uh
lauren cohan who played maggie she's
british too
yeah she came she's pretty good yeah it
sounded southern
yeah there's a lot of variation in the
southern in the south that's true
and the thing about when you do like a
british accent yeah that
i'm like which british accent are you
talking about there are so many
right um i don't know i could tell what
area of mississippi you're from based on
your [ __ ]
well that's what i mean and people from
the uk are the same they're like they
can pretty much tell what town you're
from by
how you talk and um i think and i saw
somebody like comment that earlier it's
like that's what happens when you have
like for thousands like for a thousand
years people that didn't go any farther
than 20 miles from their hometown for
like a long time
it's like everybody's going to sound the
same and you're going to know exactly
where they come from
yeah so all the descendants of all the
sharecroppers all sound exactly the same
pretty much
and and and a good example would be the
uh the hajj twins
the hodge twins sound like every
southern sharecropping family
no matter what their race is they all
sound like that yeah that's where my dad
sounds all his friends
all his friends sound just like that
yeah if
i wouldn't know those are black guys if
he just if i just heard the
them talking yeah yeah it's just funny
but that's just the way it is
yeah yeah but yeah i think so like i
said it wasn't it wasn't too distracting
for me as an american
um some people have said that the guy
that played um
peter quint i can't [ __ ] i can't
remember his name he was the same guy
that played luke in haunting of hill
house
which is funny because when he played
luke in haunting of hill house it didn't
occur to me that he was not american
however he is not
so he when he was doing an accent in
this one i was like wow that's like a
pretty decent scottish accent he's
not scottish but he is english so
because he played an american
in haunting of hill house and it didn't
occur to me that he wasn't american i
guess because i hadn't seen him in
anything else
so uh because i don't see a lot of tv
apparently he's been in a [ __ ] ton of
other stuff as well
also i really liked that i saw alex
esso in this she was she wasn't in it
very much because she played
um she played flora and miles's mom
charlotte um who you know obviously the
beginning of story's dead but she's like
you know they show her flashbacks and
[ __ ]
um and i you know she did a pretty
passable english accent too i thought
um i first saw her in starry eyes like
back in 2014 which i loved it was a
great [ __ ] movie
and she also played wendy in
dr sleep which was another mike flanagan
because mike flanagan i don't know if
you know tom but
uh dr sleep was directed by mike
flanagan who was the same guy that
did this and haunting a pill house now
on this doctor sleep better
now on the this is like he i guess
like the first like haunting of hill
house i think he directed the whole
thing this one
he only directed the first episode which
is called a great good place
and then the rest of them he was just
like the show runner so he just like
oversaw the whole story and like just
kind of
and then it was like a handful of other
directors that worked on it
but it seemed like everybody did a
pretty good job of um
kind of matching his style because it
didn't occur to me that other people had
directed it like it wasn't a weird tonal
shift or anything
um just as in the first one uh the
[ __ ] production design the set design
beautiful uh the house is just gorgeous
like the whole
theme of it like all the outside with
all the mist and everything like that
was super cool
it just like looked really cool uh the
ghosts were really cool like the one
lady or the lady the lake or whatever
they call her um you know the
with the without the face and [ __ ] like
that because they showed that on the
poster
um were also really cool but you know
like i think another criticism that
people might have
i didn't mind this at all but it did
seem like
they kind of left they did like they did
really good opening like with all these
kind of mysteries like what's up with
these [ __ ] weird kids and what the
hell is going on with this house and
what happened to their parents and
what's the deal with this like creepy
ass dude that's like
that you can see in mirrors that has
like these big like [ __ ] shiny fiery
eyes like
that follows danielle around it's like
what the hell is that all about
so they did that and then like but then
like in the middle it seems like it took
a long time for some of that [ __ ] to get
resolved you know what i'm saying
so it's like it was kind of like um
you know they set all these mysteries up
and then they just kind of like instead
of revealing them slowly over the thing
it's you know it was like the fifth or
sixth episode before you like found out
any big like revelations or anything
so because they kind of spent a lot of
time in there
setting [ __ ] up but i will say that 99
of the mysteries that were set up do get
solved like by the end of it
from like five episode five on um
the only one that didn't get sent like i
said i'm not really gonna spoil it
because i don't really want to but there
was
one mystery it wasn't like central to
the whole story or anything but there
was one that i
did i don't think was ever resolved or
they never really like
explained uh but you know it wasn't a
big major thing it was just one thing
that i was like oh hey they brought that
up once and
then they didn't like follow up on it or
they didn't like say what actually
happened there
um so that's going to be the only thing
that i'm going to bother with like
because 99 of the [ __ ] that they
said and that they set up and everything
like that like totally came to fruition
at the end
so like i said this one is i mean
haunting of hill house
was like scary but it was also like
really sad
this one less scary but way more sad i
mean this one i think was
really sad you know what i mean um you
know i wasn't like
bawling at the end like or anything like
that but it's like it does kind of like
a lot of [ __ ] happens it's kind of like
a bummer it's like not a bummer but it's
like
bittersweet you know what i mean but you
know
i your mileage may vary i don't know i
feel like people are
um not liking it as much as haunting of
hill house
which like i said i i can see that
because it's not as
creepy but i think it has
i liked the story a lot more and i think
it had like a lot more kind of
emotional [ __ ] going on and i liked that
instead of just following one family it
was just like
a bunch of different relationships but
they were all like thematically related
and i really like the idea of
essentially making
an extended universe with like
a classic uh ghost story writer you know
in this case henry james so i thought
that was like a really cool idea like
taking a bunch of his stories
um and kind of like adapting them into
one larger narrative
you know i thought that was like a
really cool idea and i'm kind of
surprised that that's not done more
often
i guess he kind of did that a little bit
with haunting of hill house but
i feel like there wasn't a lot of other
stuff in there that related to other
shirley jackson stuff
but this one very clearly i mean one
episode
was pretty much a straight up um was a
straight-up adaptation of
uh the romance of whatever was the
romance of old clothes or whatever it
was called
was pretty much a straight-up adaptation
of that ghost story and
one was also kind of like a riff on the
jolly corner which is
one of his better known uh stories as
well so
if that sounds like something you'd be
into definitely uh
just rife with easter eggs particularly
if you're into like classic
literature classic ghost story type of
[ __ ] um
so yeah and hopefully i didn't spoil
anything
too much for anybody but uh yeah
that's yeah tammy said i felt sorry for
some of the characters i didn't think i
liked when they were first introduced
i think they did a good job i'm going to
say particularly peter quinn's character
of making him not necessarily
sympathetic
because he is a bad guy i mean he is a
villain but
making his motivations like
understandable
you know what i mean so i i really
really like that they were able to do
that and i
honestly i liked pretty much all the
characters like i said i think mrs gross
and owen were my favorite thank you
mango convince me to watch it
you might like it you might not like i
said now some i've i have seen some
people saying oh it's not as good as
haunting a hill house and it's like
you know it's not scary enough it's not
you know it's too much of a romance and
too much of a
blah blah but i mean it is like a very
it's a pretty standard if you know
anything about gothic literature it's a
pretty standard gothic
uh you know literature kind of
adaptation
but just without like the overt
scariness of like haunting a pillow
house i guess like it's a more
scariness but when you get to the end
there's
you know there's a lot of ghost [ __ ]
going on there too and the [ __ ] with
danny and like the ghosts or whatever
that is that's following her around
that's kind of like your scares at the
beginning part and then that kind of
goes on and then it goes into a
different story so it just didn't pull
me and didn't really kind of have that
it didn't have the driving kind of
storyline
and behind it's like you said it's old
gothic horror yeah
it feels victorian the thinking behind
it feels victorian
yeah which is not real you know what i
mean
how should i say it it's not a real
[ __ ] high energy to me it's slow burn
stuff
it's yeah it's slow burn and it is very
like um tilan says some are saying this
playing out like a soap opera more drama
than scary yeah
that is that is fair i would say it's
kind of i don't want to call it a chick
flick it's not really a chick flick
no not really but it has i think i think
these kind of stories appeal more to the
to to the female personality they just
think they do
yeah it's not as hands-on the story it's
all inner psychology and
and it it it's at the inner world of
thinking and worrying about stuff you
know what i mean it's
you're dealing with a problem that you
can't really [ __ ] get a good grip on
there's nothing you can physically do
about it
well yeah because it's like supernatural
yeah and and for some
reason women like those stories more
than guys
guys i think because guys get frustrated
too much by a situation like that
well we like more complicated yeah and
be like well i can't [ __ ] punch it i
don't want to punch the [ __ ] out of that
where's this [ __ ] ghost i'm gonna
kick that ghost's ass
you gotta man and you can't do it i
really like stuff that you can punch i'm
gonna punch that [ __ ]
and you can't punch it so you don't want
to talk about it i don't want to talk
about that [ __ ] can't kick its ass can't
kick its ass there's nothing you could
do
you know what that made me think of like
you saying that that made me think of
that episode of a haunting
yeah that ed dunham
yeah he does too because he lives around
here yeah but uh
ed was an ex-army ranger and he [ __ ]
house and it just like made him mad that
the house was on and he couldn't do
anything but yeah
he kept seeing the apparition i was
doing it in the [ __ ] house i just
want to beat it up
saw dude in the house like a smoking
cigar what are you doing in here what
are you doing in here [ __ ] attacked
that [ __ ] thing
and then he kept hearing footsteps up on
the roof never could see anything and he
challenged the [ __ ]
challenge it to [ __ ] fight and yeah
because you can't fight a ghost and he
got pissed
but that's what makes them scarier in my
opinion
i mean yeah and and what they have to do
nuts though
well yeah but i i mean i can see that i
can see being frustrated by problems
that aren't
like easily solved or aren't solved with
like you know
physical means yeah that that that
episode if you want to see it it was
like season one or two of the haunting
and it was called a haunting in florida
yeah i think and it happened right up
this road here in deltona i've been to
that house i've seen that house
yeah we did it yeah we did a note and we
also did a
show on and i know ed dunham he's on my
friend's list he
he's a uh he's doing [ __ ] around here
now uh
he was marrying people for a while as if
he was he was a minister how many oh
he became a damn army minister i thought
you meant he was married
like you just married people right then
divorce
he put on a kilt and [ __ ] put on his
[ __ ] piece yeah he'd put on a [ __ ]
tartan
and [ __ ] uh put you in front of a big
old [ __ ] army raider sign if i could
marry you
i killed an army yeah yeah that's all
you need if you wanted to be married by
an army ranger he'd do it
yeah yeah he had to he had that justice
of peace
power yeah so that's what he was doing
well [ __ ] you can get that online
nowadays yeah get that [ __ ]
for like five or ten dollars or that's
what it is that but it used to be better
he'd put on a whole
ceremony he'd give you an army maybe
it's more than that now he'd give you an
army wedding
that's pretty funny yeah tammy said uh
definitely a slow burn but the ending is
worth it oh yeah it definitely is
and i that's kind of one thing because i
was reading um
i can't remember what blog it was maybe
it was a av club or something like that
they've been doing like a episode by
episode breakdown so she's reviewing
each episode as she's watching it and so
she doesn't know what's going to happen
and apparently she's i don't know if
she's never read turn the screw but like
i said this
this goes off in like slightly different
directions so even if you've read that
you're not really going to know where
it's going
but um it's interesting to see like the
predictions that she made and like
because
me like having watched the whole thing
i'm sitting there going well no
you're right about that but you're wrong
about that and all this other kind of
stuff
so i can't but i can see how people
might get frustrated because they
feel like you know oh the the first
couple like the first episode or two are
like really good and you like
introduce all these mysteries and then
like for a couple episodes it seems like
it's not
progressing on that or it's not like
working on those mysteries
but like i said if you watch the whole
thing through it like really solves
pretty much
99 of the [ __ ] that you were asking
about
and it really does kind of like uh tie
everything up really well at the end i
thought
but you really have to like you know
i've seen this called this is a very
patient you have to be very very patient
with it and like i said this is another
one that
is definitely going to be like better on
rewatch just like haunting of hill house
was because
now you know the resolution so now you
can see
like everything that was set up like
knowing what's going to happen in the
end
talking about this and talking about ed
ed dunham and
makes me want to see ghost brothers
again i wonder if that shows
i was yeah i was just wondering about
that the other day if that show was
still anybody know if ghost brothers is
still on
that that [ __ ] was [ __ ] funny
yeah we didn't see that many of them but
it's like i just caught it on tv every
now and then yeah
and uh i just like i didn't even care
about the ghost [ __ ] i just thought they
were
[ __ ] hilarious i just thought they
were funny i was like they don't have to
go explore haunted [ __ ] they could just
like hang out and talk
scared of [ __ ] it wouldn't be funny oh
no i can't take this
ken says how's the cookbook coming along
we actually um
i have a couple other projects i have to
finish first like i said i've got all
the [ __ ] done but like in two weeks i
want to like
get in there and like finish it finish
it right because like i said i got all
the page layouts done
uh we just have to just go through and
get the delivery right i just have to go
through and get the delivery right and
and like you know get the pictures put
in and show you yeah it's not like you
start at the beginning and start writing
[ __ ]
it's not really like that it's you got
to get all the information yeah it's
going to be like you got to flash it out
and then you got to kind of humanize it
yeah and you know i got to get in there
and [ __ ] so we are still working on
it
i'm still shooting for getting done by
christmas we'll see how it goes
because we still have a couple weeks may
or may not happen it'll probably happen
it'll probably happen because i mean
like i said as
because i've got a couple things i
wanted to finish by halloween which i'm
on track to finish you got the vegan
cookbook it's uh it's up there once you
grab that show them what we're talking
about
we're not talking about a cheap cookbook
this shit's gonna look cool
well yeah i think it's going to look
cool it's up there
it's right there satanic spell book yeah
that's it your fingers right yeah
yeah that's right there right there
right next to the edward gory book
yes hardcover yeah we probably showed
this before this is a vegan black metal
chef who is a friend of ours
and uh this is his cookbook which i
designed he wrote it obviously and took
all the photos
but i'm the one that designed it but
yeah so he has like
like all this kind of stuff yeah it's
gonna it's gonna be something going the
wrong way
yeah and you know yeah
it's kind of not gonna look exactly like
that obviously because that's kind of
his
aesthetic yeah this but it's gonna be
we're just talking about the quality
yeah yeah it's gonna be real high
quality yeah i'm definitely doing uh
definitely doing a hardback because
paperbacks for a cookbook i don't know
i just always feel like cookbooks should
be i've seen i mean the gordon ramsay
one is
is paperback and that's fine but
probably each section
has to have themes will visually have a
certain theme too
that's what i'm thinking of doing
because i kind of did this one
what i did with this one was i just like
because he kind of had this broken up in
a different like cuisines like this is
the indian cuisine this is italian or
whatever
and i just made them like slightly
different like different colors
so like so you'd be able to kind of like
flip through and see like
get to the one that you wanted to get to
but um you know so
i'm not really sure that's probably how
we'll organize ours as well um
i don't know we'll see because some of
the stuff that we want to do like is
there's
crossover with other [ __ ] and i don't
know
and like you said you wanted to do some
[ __ ] with um you could do some mexican
food in there too
well yeah we're gonna do mexican food
you're gonna do indian food
maybe thai food chinese food
southern american food
like your biscuits and gravy and all
that kind of stuff
we gotta do all that kind of stuff right
so uh like i said we've got the we've
got the list done out
of all the recipes we're gonna do and
i've got like the um
all the page templates like all set up
like how i'm gonna
like lay everything out like once we get
all the text
finalized so as i said hopefully have it
done by christmas we'll see how it goes
and it is going to be hard back
so yeah uh yeah like i said if
if you're looking for something like
[ __ ] that'll like scare the [ __ ] out
of you it's
this is not that but if you're into like
classic or
gothic horror or something like that
then you should uh definitely give this
a watch because
i i think you'll l i think you'll
appreciate it more like after it's over
and then because now that it's over and
like i know what happened and i'm just
like oh [ __ ] now
now i gotta go back and watch it again
because like apparently look
because i missed a bunch of [ __ ] um
pretty much everything in there
like ties together you know what i mean
the letter like refers back to something
else so it's actually like really really
well written
but yeah it's on netflix obviously um so
go binge it
and tell me what you thought of it and
uh we have do you have anything else you
would like to
add all right so i guess the next live
stream we're gonna do is our saturday
night
show oh yeah yeah we got to do that yeah
[Laughter]
what i was thinking i forgot what the
topic was going to be i told you like
a minute before we started this last
year i just [ __ ] slipped just in my
mind
i'm sleepy right now so am i okay
i woke up at 5 30. all right you'll tell
me what you'll tell me when you shut it
down
yeah i will i'll tell you you know what
it is you know what it is
well yeah i have some well i hope so i
obviously have to know what it is
because i'm the one that has to do all
the research
[Laughter]
you know what it is and uh and and i'm
the one that has to set up all the
patreons she said
she's crying
well yeah well no because i buy buy you
[ __ ] and stuff like that it just goes
off
money is money it get it and i don't
like buy anything fun with it i just
paid bills
[Laughter]
you know what i mean money's money yeah
money's money
tom's getting old for getting everything
says louie
it doesn't matter then oracle says tom
do you need an old man nap he probably
right he probably
yes i wish i could nap during the day i
just can't i can't sleep when it's daily
yeah
i'm suffering from those conditions of
low estrogen
low estrogen yes let's call it you get
sleepy
it's hormonal imbalances and [ __ ] what
don't you always have low estrogen
no it gets no you know man
you're trying to give me talk about
[ __ ] hormonology and biology
[Laughter]
testosterone aromatizes into estrogen
okay
you have to have a certain amount of
estrogen in your body the estrogen
testosterone ratio okay yeah i know that
well when you start [ __ ] around when
you start [ __ ] around with your
hormones
like you do like i do i take some
certain things
that look like testosterone
but they aren't testosterone so your own
body backs off on the production of
testosterone because you think you got
enough
okay it's like oh you got that kind of
you got it yeah the problem my
problem is is that the testosterone
mimickers do not aromatize into estrogen
uh-huh so it it just falls apart
it's fooling the body into thinking that
yeah so you need more girl juices
i need girl juice that's why one day one
day i went and said you got a birth
control pill
yeah i got one that's not estrogen
that's not the right kind
yeah that was a difficult i thought they
were estrogen you take a little bit of
estrogen and then you'll [ __ ] wake
right back up
[Laughter]
but you go through you go through cycles
you take the [ __ ] for a couple weeks
and then you start feeling kind of sleep
and then you come off of it and for a
couple weeks you just
recover and then you're going on your
own hormones and then you [ __ ]
replace them
that's for hormone replacement therapy i
mean girls know all about that girls
know all about it because it's the same
thing
girls have been [ __ ] with their
hormones forever well and plus
control and plus like i said we we know
all about [ __ ] horrible cycles even
before you take birth control pills
because you're [ __ ]
right i've been dealing with that [ __ ]
since i was like 12 years old i just
you get it you get up just get up to a
certain size and if you [ __ ]
lift and just work out and you work
yourself to the bone it'll take you
weeks to heal back up that's just too
long
you know what i mean you you're not
going to grow at the right size so
you've got to
what i what i'm taking it accelerates
healing
you know and things that are like
testosterone always accelerate healing
yeah so you know [ __ ] maybe if i was
14 or 15 years old yeah maybe i'd be
able to keep up with that workout
that workout routine but i can't keep up
with it now take too long to heal up
yeah you know and then if you go on
[ __ ] steroids
or [ __ ] straight up hormone
replacement therapy where you take an
exogenous testosterone you can bump it
up to have like the testosterone level
of like
14 12 year olds 14 15 year olds
you don't need that you don't need that
but those [ __ ] people
are around like a little those gigantic
[ __ ] huge [ __ ]
mass monsters if you take their blood
save you take a blood sample off them
they go
god damn dude you got ten times the
[ __ ] testosterone count as a fifteen
have you been
eating 14 years old boys what the [ __ ]
it's just too much goddamn testosterone
but you see you when you see them dudes
it's it's not
use that's not that's not drug use
that's drug abuse
uh yeah they're taking too much of that
[ __ ] that's why they [ __ ]
end up dying [ __ ] early that shit's
real hard on your heart and your liver
yep you just want enough to just bump
you up to
so you grow faster than you normally
would it takes about five years
and once you get there you just maintain
that
yeah you know what i mean it's it's that
transformation
from grasshopper to locust that's what
you're [ __ ] doing
yes indeed or from bruce banner to the
home from bruce
banner to the [ __ ] hulk louie says i
need more girl juice belongs on a shirt
[Laughter]
damn there's another one god damn it we
have i still gotta make
my favorite one so far was i say
whatever comes out of my mouth so we
definitely need
that's gonna be sure see mango knows
about hrt
the problem about hrt is i want to go on
hrt hrt is hormone replacement therapy
that's what you talk about the problem
with hrt
is that you want to go on it you want to
go on hrt
as late as possible because as soon as
you get on [ __ ] testosterone and
you can get prescribed here in the us as
soon as you go on that [ __ ] you won't
want to come back off
because that [ __ ] feels good you're like
oh yeah until it doesn't
well no you keep the right you keep the
route the level of it right
you can have the testosterone level of a
[ __ ] 25 or 30 year old until you die
they got guys that do it
they're they're [ __ ] in their 80s
that are doing that
and you just feel [ __ ] awesome you
feel like a kid you're like oh yeah i'm
gonna hit that
yeah i'm gonna hit that too yeah i'm
gonna hit that also
this so sometimes you have to put those
guys on mood stabilizers to keep them
out of trouble
well yeah because they're just trying to
hit it they're just like sexual assault
yes it's waiting to happen
well if he looks good maybe he could
maybe he could pull it off
but a lot of those guys don't so they
put them on their mood stabilizers
baby running away from them screaming
yeah
get away from me crazy man i was just
happy to be noticing that uh
booty you got here and i was thinking
yeah yeah tell me how that works out
yeah that's like that no
got the [ __ ] libido of a 14 year old
in the
body of an 80 year old yeah oh my god
imagine that [ __ ] that's horrifying yeah
that's my next horror story right there
hormones are a hell of a drug yeah they
are yeah
all right are we shutting this [ __ ] down
yeah so
what i was saying was is you don't want
to go on hrt until
until you absolutely have to and because
you won't want to come off of it
ken said that was hornida's replacement
tequila
yeah which i thought was very fun
yeah all right so we will see you guys
again live
on saturday so have a good time tomorrow
since then we got a couple taped things
going up tomorrow and friday
so enjoy those in the meantime and we'll
see you later
bye